12 14 16 18 yeah thank you
um against
the against the you got to have a little
Spice in the speech right I mean you got
to have a little
fun America I think it's you you have
the American people by and large have
affinity for Israel part largely I think
more from in in our Christian Community
than anything just based on on the
history of the judeo-christian tradition
and how it's informed this country so I
think it is unique in terms of the the
Affinity that our country has for Israel
because of the of the Biblical history
and people's uh adherence to the
judeo-christian tradition yeah earlier
today uh so I want to stick with those
Affinity towards Israel Biblical history
Jud judeo you hear this a lot the judeo
Christian history and this is why the
support is coming what you what is your
reaction to that well this term
judeo-christian um values I never heard
it until about 20 years ago 20 years ago
so this was a phrase that was dropped in
somebody created This this
term propagandas and they dropped it
into the minds of people and you started
hearing it over and over and over our
judeo-christian heritage
and a lot of us were going what what do
you mean America doesn't have a Jewish
Christian
Heritage but that was the message
America has a Jewish Christian
Heritage so the took ownership of
America uh I mean that's literally what
they're doing they're saying hey uh the
Zionist yes the Zionist the zionists
were claiming ownership of the founding
of America this country has a
judeo-christian
Heritage well it
doesn't but it's it's a propaganda
technique and now it's it's said so
often that nobody questions it it's just
accept
it and when guys like me say it's hey
that that's
propaganda then we're we're crit I'm
criticized as though I don't know what
I'm talking about but I'll tell you
Eddie I've got a long
memory and I can remember a lot of
things and I can remember the way things
were
before and I I know when certain
propaganda messages were dropped into
the
society but most people don't most
people don't have a long memory let me
get into this uh next clip here in
cultures in and that's I think what's
happened there's no go zones in France
and in uh in in Britain in some of these
places that's not a recipe for Success
so I think Europe's going to have a very
difficult time with these tensions
bubbling up I think we have the ability
to still be smart about what we're doing
here in the United States um and avoid
some of what what they've walked
themselves into I I just I just hope and
and pray that this thing doesn't get
ugly I know you got three kids I got
four we uh uh you know when you think
from your kids perspective it's a little
bit concerning when you're seeing this
is not calming down it's getting worse
and it's like bar was like what' you say
what you say and everybody's like did
you see what he said and it's just
getting more and more and more heated
and we got to kind of figure out bring
it
down I like what uh Patrick B David was
saying we got to figure out a way to
calm it down and I want to address this
nogo zones in uh in I think he said
France and I think this is this is
incorrect what the governor is all do
respect uh this is not true these no-o
zones that Muslims would love I mean I
mean you can probably when you're en
Jordan and whatnot they paint this
picture as Muslims are barbarians you go
over there going to cut your head off I
mean they'd love for you to come in any
neighborhood come and eat with us sit
with us you know you you've experienced
that right I think the zantis needs to
go to Jordan or wherever you were and to
see it for himself I mean so when they
say there's no go zones and all this
other nonsense but you do have
unfortunately you do have and that's you
know the situation with the apartheid
now you do have IDF soldiers who will
come out and they'll testify this is not
you know M we're not making this up you
have streets there that are used
specifically for zionists for people who
follow not Moses's teachings but Theodor
Herzel you know and you cannot go you
cannot go down these streets and you
have two sets of laws you know one for
people who's who's zionists and uh the
right of return only for certain people
this is Injustice I'm an Israeli Jewish
American as well my partner is
Palestinian and I can do things that he
can't do um I can travel quite freely
and even though his mother is a refugee
from from what is now Israel he can't
pass areas that are off limits to
Palestinians I have um excellent rights
I have health there are cities in Israel
being built for Jews only and also in
the West Bank settlements being built
for Israeli Jews only while Palestinians
are hemmed in unable to build cities and
their homes are being demolished for
lack of permits that are almost
impossible to get um the Israeli
authorities are engaging in forcible
transfer where they remove Palestinian
communities in the West Bank to make
room for settlements all of these are
part of the root causes of the violence
there's terrible abuses going on you
just have to listen to what people on
the ground are telling you and adjust
accordingly this is what Nelson Mandela
also was against and Jimmy Carter called
this apartheid state Etc so um how would
you respond uh to this I like what
Patrick said about we got to have level
heads we got to calm this thing down
well I would say I agree but the ruling
class of America is deliberately doing
the
opposite they need the tension they need
the anger they need the
division the the ruling class of America
is not trying to calm things down
they're trying to Jack things up they're
trying to get people angry at each other
they want us fighting at each other
Eddie they don't want you and me to do
what we're doing right
now having a a civilized conversation
between two gentlemen they don't want it
they want us yelling at each other look
at the news shows look at how they do
everything is shouting yelling
everything that they've done to America
in the last 20 years has been to divide
us make us angry make us afraid they're
doing it to the whole world yesterday uh
it may have been on Monday Vladimir
Putin uh gave a speech in Russia and he
said the globalists I don't know what I
think he said the the rulers of the
West need chaos to stay in
power and that they're doing it to the
whole
world I mean everywhere they're setting
the world on fire they did it with
Ukraine they have it now happening in
the Middle East the next spot will be
Asia they need the world to be in chaos
they need people to be fighting each
other and so we we defeat them by doing
the opposite of what they
want don't let them make you angry don't
let them make you fear other
people do the opposite of what they're
programming you and me to do certain
things to think a certain way to talk a
certain way don't give into
it you you mentioned the
hospitality of the Arabic people I I've
I I was amazed in my trips to Jordan
strangers would invite me to their home
for
dinner I'd start a conversation and they
would say please please come over to my
dinner oh come over to my house for
dinner let's let's continue this
conversation wonderful people but you
know the first time I went to a
Palestinian area was as 2018 I went into
uh Bethlehem I had been in St Petersburg
Russia attending a conference and
decided at the last minute to fly to to
Tel Aviv and attend the Christ at the
checkpoint conference in Bethlehem which
is held by a group of Palestinian
Christians trying to get American
Christians to understand what's
happening in
Palestine and Eddie when I told friends
that I was going to um the West Bank I
had so many well-meaning people who
cared about me and they said now Rick
you got to you got to think about this
you're going over there and they're
they're going to try to behead
you wow I'm not and they were sincere
they were really afraid they thought I'm
going my life was in
danger and when I came back and said no
they were
wonderful they were awesome I I've got
new friends and everywhere I went I was
treated kindly they were like that can't
be true these were the these were the
Palestinians there yes the Palestinians
in the in the in Bethlehem in the West
Bank they treated me with such kindness
I didn't ask are you a Christian are you
a Muslim I didn't they just were people
they're just people I just accept people
for being people all right I don't want
to put a label on anybody I just want to
accept people for being
people but the ruling class of America
wants us to Mark everybody put a label
on them fight with them argue with them
divide
conquer don't communicate
separate why because they stay in power
when we're divided MH and when we refuse
to be angry with others when we refuse
to hate when we refuse to be afraid they
lose power I cannot leave without giving
you a gift if you're not yet Muslim and
you tuning in to see what these Muslims
are talking about and you like a free
copy of the Quran go ahead and visit
theen show.com we'll take care of the
postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions about Islam call us at 1
662 4752 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you Alam alum